Oh on screen I guess I guess we're here
yeah
I've completely forgotten how to play so
how do we start our cars
oh god my my accent lights aren't on
hang on trying to get my hand on the
steering you guys start
yeah there's it just it we're just doing
it how do we do foot on I have no idea
about foot first gear first gear all
right so I'm in first
are you moving no I think I got to start
this car well there's a button I'm
upside down
I got a false start false start what
does that mean I wrecked oh my god you
you have to steer it oh Jesus
can someone flip me over how do you flip
I don't know I mean hard button well was
it the button on the steering wheel it
might have been I can restart us if you
guys want it no my steering wheel is
gone frame stop like somebody is a
winning the rate and they're mine
frames I Boop the button oh yeah I'm
ready to it
Oh what the hell how are you doing that
okay you're gonna go down town that
second gear about it whatever yeah
second gear was a mistake gearbox is not
happy with me so I'm gonna drive a
manual anyway so guys just lettin whoo
it's ready so fast not me I was trying
to grab the balls that's so like you
who is drifting ahead whoo that's way
somehow we got ahead of us I got a false
start penalty yeah you would
you're right I got my hand on her
steering wheel who I have
oh yeah I'm going for it
oh here we go first gear all the way I
am killing it
cruisin hyah drifting cruising forward
all right i'ma try to shift gears here
oh my god it's so loud my engine is
stuck on and it won't on engine change
the gears works I'm totally freaking
hell all right so you gotta get you got
to get your hand like locked on it like
the gear shifter thingy oh that's smart
oh that's a smart thing because then you
just yeah you're smart yeah yeah yeah
wait wait wait I can't grab him wheel
wait no mark oh that's not me I'm gonna
someone's gonna win this time I'm gonna
win baby oh it's a boat you guys suck so
much you do not go so fast go slowly
oh god oh god oh god oh geez Oh God
gravity is real funny here in this town
I would say as a person who's driven a
car before this is not this is not and
that's all I want to say about that
oh it's not filling it Jesus Christ okay
this is the worst thing I ever done I
try trying to get myself situated here
my hand won't go to steering wheel my
steering wheels gone that's fine that's
fine everything's fine what do you mean
that's not fine fine it seems fair to me
how's that all right fine
you want it you want to go bro I'll go
I'll go gearbox only try me ah don't try
me oh wait don't don't don't no this is
where we're going baby
Oh turn turn turn well I got a nice
beautiful wall here no ketchup crusher
diet you won't
how do you beat my time I'm an expert
that's not right you guys let me win one
just so I can know how it feels
No
sir oh my steering wheels go on frames
what what yes restart right away what
happens when you make me the leader of
the party yeah I guess that is what
happens when we do that okay so for some
reason now the steering wheel is a
serial entity from beyond this dimension
really patience
okay here we go here we go here we go
okay that's the first that is river the
in fact reverse alright I got the top
gear I'm gonna win this time
no marks already gone oh you know that's
me baby you you know who else has the
top gear this guy oh yeah well you are
waiting bomb our way oh it's coming yeah
[Laughter]
I'll take the win I'm here I'm feeling
it now 23 seconds Bob now I got the top
gear really fast it was awesome I'm
gonna try to change gears also I'm a
mangled corpse
I think I'm dangling wind up so should
we keep doing this you shut your mouth
I'm gonna kick Bob's ass okay I'm
starting it off wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I was not ready you oh you're
like oh we're gonna kick your ass wait
my car's not going listen car if you
could just if you can just go into gear
oh no someone's really going for it I
got it I got it I shifted gears yeah you
can't beat me now oh no I'm steering I'm
steering
I'm steer oh yeah I'm locked on target
okay my hand god oh god that's the
ticket it's working everything it's
working I'm so glad I'm glad for you
really mark great it's great it's real
you have not you having a win over there
no I you know winter it was you know
it's funny I was actually I am a winner
in general I've won three times I I have
won
I'm a winner are you guys done with this
race
yeah frames please
okay I got a false start come on Trey I
can't see I'm gonna save this I'm gonna
save it
oh no no don't get in my way
oh you see me am i dead yeah yeah you're
dead you're dead okay
[Applause]
shipping oh god no oh god no not like
this I'm so close for some reason when
you shift gears it throws your entire
body weight against the car and the car
is like weighs 2 ounces I think I won I
think you won wait that's a good win
here we go again
wait do you sound like you're not having
a fun time I'm not good at this one at
all man none of us have ever experienced
that all started how did I fall stir
what when you hold sort you don't get to
drive anymore that's what you get oh
who's that you waiter is that mark I
know I'm going on ask me baby oh me oh
me all day oh me all day oh I got to
watch mark the upside come on wait right
there
I'm fine having some ball trouble sounds
like a personal problem yeah a little
bit
did we win Bob well mark didn't win
that's for sure I think the only trick
is to slam it into fifth gear and hold
on for dear life because there's no
other way there's no way you're shifting
do we try it one more time just see what
happened yeah yeah yeah all right let's
do I'm just gonna watch you two go from
here and see what happens to you guys
I'm sure whatever man
wait wait wait wait wait you guys why
can't a gear I caught a gear all right
what this is what Oh God oh it's fast
now Mark's going go it's fast oh it's
wishy-washy
oh dear I'm gonna die now leaving you I
believe in you
right now I was trying so desperately to
shift I could have just driven down the
race and third God dang it yeah yeah my
hand teleported off of the wheel I told
you the wheel is like a ghost from
another reality yeah no it is like this
this is fun
I think everyone's having fun all right
yeah yeah I got some bills to pay
all right whoever wins this one gets a
thousand subscribers this that's the
deal
all right youtuber twitch OOP you do
okay okay I died a heart attack my
character is dead I got a good start oh
I got it I got it into first and out of
first I actually dead oh I got into
first out of first event in the fifth
and I'm navigating around marks dead
body this is the one one Bob was it how
did we get worse I died when I shifted
gears that's a new problem the person in
the car dead that's a you problem
it's a funny problem now isn't it yeah
that's pretty good button let's just
talk this over okay okay what are we
talking about all right well that's
about anything you know wait who hit the
button mark hit the bun no no no I don't
know my kid I don't have hands anything
good boy
you did this to you I'm gonna hit them I
got almost in the second eye I went on
first a second by the way
I'm crawling out of the car oh this is a
record-setting win is a record real air
damn it ah never gonna top it never here
we seem to be in the street and and and
shift into gear just any okay well I was
still doing stuff but that's fine well I
thought my very loud struggling we were
all dead all right let's all very okay
trying to grab the steering wheel
so I see you Bob see you Bart yeah
oh that second gear can I get third gear
yeah that's holy geez who hit me
it was my backdraft that was just so
much air that I was displacing for my
speed I think the key is you really
gotta smack the shifts I think that's
the key right you sick of this yet wait
no no no no all right I'm gonna try to
shift this time no that's sir that's
third that's third that's there I'd like
to say that wasn't my god damn it god
damn it shifted laughter you guys trying
to flip someone off stop fondling the
balls and move just go into fifth gear
come on come on a different game here oh
hey we're all dead yeah yeah oh yeah
this how did I this is this hell is this
what hell is
[Laughter]
oh my god oh you got me oh my god this
is my racket oh yeah I went forgot oh no
I slapped it back in the first Qin way
from first to second tougher get out of
my way Oh Oh God oh please get up yes
worse than last you don't need to tell
me that game that drive like I do in
real life
hand on lap on middle finger out the
left window middle finger out the right
[ __ ] the police Flags
giving you that sweep you see my middle
finger on my window no no I don't know
if you're my right or my left
oh I kind of see it thanks man this is
for you
Wade oh yes I see it thanks man
you're welcome oh [ __ ] Oh God I think I
fall started oh dear well I'm gonna just
park right in front of you guys no this
is reverse how did you get it insert
that's the bottom right on the pattern
oh you're on dude good run come on come
on get into fifth god damn it did you
shift how did you make your car go in a
straight line guys I hate to tell you
this but I did use not just the wheel at
all you should just not touch we've
learned the trick I swear guys I just
went in a perfectly straight line my
Miller is on the window so impress that
button I got it don't fall start
apparently you're stupid damn it there
we go hey Bob Quebec hang on I got a
beat mark lost a lot of speed on that
gear change there but I think I'm gonna
make it look I'm coming I'm coming for
you you see my middle finger off the
window no I don't know I don't know
no god I can't crab that's the best race
we've had yet wait you really just don't
want to touch the steering wheel at all
hi I knew from the moment I saw it as an
ethereal entity from another dimension
that it was probably not good for us to
deal with all right guys you got your
middle fingers out the window oh I'm
ready I'm where do you wait is nowhere
near ready come on wait that middle
finger proudly out the window let's do
this
come on wait hey come on that's not out
the window that's in your car gotta be
out all right here we go guys good race
good race good luck
oops I think I had just fall started
freaking heck here we go got it
much cut weight office to ruin his day
no pump oh oh oh [ __ ] look how fast that
was oh that's a new that's I shade
through every gear per almost perfectly
oh my god well now I have something to
strive for yeah come on
come on you got this the key is
absolutely the middle finger yeah it's
what gives you your aerodynamicist
boys okay I didn't even I didn't even
[Music]
Oh second Oh God come on Oh God Oh oh no
I'm fearing / I hit I hit the wheel
I actually yes No again frames
technically that was faster
wait frames God dang it really it really
is the middle finger out the window huh
yeah and not bumping the steering wheel
here but don't it's a drag race don't
steer Only Fools would do such a thing
yeah got it oh good start good start
good start
well good shift good shift good shift
good chip yeah here we go
I'm not even gonna try to shift I'm just
gonna try to go finish lunch shift
fourth oh I'm in fourth now I want to
get sub 20 seconds yes well you hit the
button when you're ready I'm ready
what my arm is do it I hit the wheel a
little bit but I think it's okay click
yes why aren't you going into gear Wow
why aren't you going into well I'm gonna
die now gum argh
are you trained first why aren't I going
am i winning I think you are dude come
on I was just not oh now I'm moving what
I was ahead of you what how did you win
learn good job with it there is no way
he-he-hey he got some 20 mark yeah he
got some 20 but he was not even ahead of
me good race and Mark is the slowest as
as it should be do is go straight into
like second gear and never touch
anything
I demand a rematch guys ready for this
ready I'm ready I'm ready
what full star I didn't touch the [ __ ]
[Music]
intended to restart right in a second
don't you dare I think you should I
think you should frames there don't you
dare don't you dare don't you don't
either don't either
yes holy [ __ ]
ate my ass no thank you 7.28
did you just go straight into third
shifted it is master a few shift Oh
Frick at the end well done buddy you
feel better now that you do I do I do I
do that's good because if you'd lost to
me that I've been like the worst thing
ever it would have been it would have
been it would have been it would have
been I think you did I'm very slightly I
think this going
no it weighs slightly it looks yeah well
that one that's good mark are you ought
to move on to a different game what did
you as much right next
there's artillery battle sounds pretty
silly
it was wait what I don't know what we're
looking at here I have a button so my
old god what I can walk oh no we have to
get in artillery shell I'm gonna grab it
with both hands it's just too girthy for
me to possibly oh wait game put I'm
stupid I wasn't showing the game to hold
hey guys welcome to artillery back oh
dear
oh goodness it's flopping around come on
get in there oh it's going in oh it's
going in what oh man this is intense
I've got it oh okay oh oh god damn it
having some trouble mark no I was so
close and I dropped it hey you guys hold
on don't blow me up just yet I gotta get
another oh I'm right about to blow you
up watch out I learned how to crouch
you're all screwed I lost an arm well
war is hell here we go
daintily pinkies up okay what do we do
once we load the thing you gotta lock it
up
prime it pull the firing cord and oh god
I hope your aim is good walk you lost me
at lock it up that's good grip know
everything yes yeah yeah I don't know
that I have to lock this I think I'm
just jerking oh yeah got it baby oh God
oh no my arm
Oh bad arm okay where where are you guys
there's one whoever is over there I
don't know no don't do it hang on give
me a second my own my own artillery
shell is trying to fire at my own face
is that good yeah yeah it's great do it
huh where's the other shooty bang but I
think you have to stand in front of it
mark I think that
and that doesn't make sense I was
thinking about that okay okay okay oh
did I find her
what Oh what the hell what oh oh no oh
did they hate it I'm not dead I think I
fired though yeah I something came near
me oh yeah
no not hell yeah don't celebrate your
own stupidness oh yeah
don't I wish there was an easier way to
raise and lower your hands oh is that
going in there frickin Frick all right
hang on can't raise it up apparently I'm
not strong enough to raise this thing up
that sounds like a you problem
that's the hole that's the whole that's
the way I like it
there we go in the hole okay now I gotta
put my hand near my crotch [ __ ] damn it
are you kidding me go in the hole go in
the hole yes I think I got my finger
stuck in there but it's okay I'm
guessing my aim was a little high Bob
I'm guessing it was just a head no idea
it's kind of like it was in the distance
okay good
am i raising or lowering what is this be
cool all right how do i fire it mark
please god haha it's on the left side no
whoa goddamn it finally got it loaded
come on not like this no you're fine
stop being a big baby
I think I'm having it Wade cuz I think I
see you aiming at me I'm not aiming at
anybody I'm trying to pick up a shell if
someone someone's gun is aimed at me and
I don't like it
I think that's mark cuz I think I shot
toward mark before and I haven't moved
the thing I don't know how to anger
thing okay getting closer
oh you sassy oh you sassy sue well no no
it's impossible to pick it up from the
ground it's impossible just crap why I
am crouched that's not the thing the
funny thing I am that's the funny thing
it just your arms out long enough to
reach it on the ground it's really
hilarious the way that is oh that sounds
funny the way you're explaining it it is
really funny it's right there grab it oh
my god please it's impossible and
crank crank crank crank crank crank quad
I keep hitting the middle mouse button
accidentally keep hitting the goddamn
Roswell's got it crank crank it crank
right all right game boys
what is up my crazy boys all right don't
worry wait it might be about to be over
it might all be over for you now so I
just told you to hold your breath please
just end me yeah oh that's so close god
damn it
it landed behind you yeah a couple more
keys oh god damn it guys you just got to
have patience guys guys I was fine I
loaded and fired so easily the first
time and then my hands broke and now
they're not this oh my god all I can see
is the insides of my [ __ ] stomach
stop uh god I love this game
crank crank crank crank crank crank
crank Ethan this is a lot of free
advertising if we could share some of
the revenue from your recent videos I
appreciate that
ah you know no one watches this stuff
come on what are you talking about damn
even here to defend himself
you guys just need to relax man I've
been trying to readjust the same goddamn
job
you're like 15 minutes will not
cooperate no matter what I do
oh no there goes my arm Oh Oh God oh
[ __ ] there goes my arm oh god wait a
little bit it's loaded I did it oh good
kill me oh I've been ready for years
please it's still too far [ __ ] okay okay
I'm letting go for a second because I'm
gonna regrab wait the other way does it
why is it continually drifting to the
right I'm literally doing all this with
one arm I don't know what you're
complaining about the one arm is
blocking my view
mayhaps oh do I have my arm back Oh
sweet like I'm Arabic someone's gonna
die eventually oh my god I am going to
blast you so hard Bob wait tell me
before you fire I want to I want to
watch I want to see how do you crouch
[ __ ] no no if you did I don't know which
ways cranking it no one's I drop I can't
tell I can tell it doesn't seem to
actually move it at all I don't
understand I don't think it's actually
doing anything we need to move the gun
or something maybe the mechanism isn't
properly engaged both my arms are gone
are you having some kind of trouble bud
yeah I've got no arms I'm just gonna
shoot Bob I I don't know if this is
correct I don't even know if I'm Bob aim
at me I don't wanna hang on all right
I'm while I'm watching and I just need
to make sure it's lined up these stupid
ammo boxes you know how it is I believe
in you okay cool all right here we go
I'm gonna get I'm gonna yank it all
right here we go here comes the yank
äj--
I'm ready I believe in you oh come on it
doesn't god sakes I'm sad you got me and
my game crashed what oh my god bomb bomb
killed board minion in my game crash
well it's time to retarget I guess
mission accomplished
definitely in space around me and all of
it is just middle fingers floating
around in my [ __ ] existence I'm sorry
you didn't okay there buddy fine how are
you
wait do you want us to back out so you
can play with us or are we doing
artillery again yeah of course take your
time
yeah I'll make a new home god damn it
[Music]